yeah thank you very good evening I'm not
sure that this might works fine thanks
yeah so this is not the first slide of
my presentation this is the slider and
please don't hesitate to other questions
still I believe that my presentation is
not very good here we go
so this will be a presentation about
OpenStreetMaps and it's an extended
vanishing of a speech which I gave on a
spike on earlier in sere and it's all
about how to how to explore new places
through API Oh
Before we jump in does this work yeah
that's a bit about myself
I graduated in nuclear physics I think
the same faculty has observed it but I
never were in that field I I've been in
data science since my graduation I open
joke about my age that I've been I
wasn't that field before the term was
invested and if you ever want to ask me
about anything not necessarily about
meant you can contact me as a victory
and
let's start on the very bottom this is
my github account where you find many
things and among those also this
presentation and the notebook note with
all possible codes so my goal today is
to convince you that each of you even
the most beginning beginner can start
using OpenStreetMaps tomorrow it's it's
a simple
I will not charm you with some highly
optimized code I'm using some basic
methods really with the hope to to tell
you it's easy to use the content of the
maps so as I said it's it's a pike on
the presentation so it all starts with a
look in the map and the idea of the
entire presentation is you look into the
map to understand the neighborhood and
neighborhood could be the place which
you're going to visit on your Sunday
trip or it could be a place where you're
considering opening a new branch or
whatever and let me make a short poll if
you go to a new place for a trip do you
ever look in the map to find whatever
you need to who does yes 100%
its hands are raised up yeah I think
it's a common it's a common and
meaningful approach what I wanted to
highlight at the Python where many
people were not from Ostrava that close
to the place you found three museums
then you found some public stops then
you find the library and the playground
for children and you can really look in
the map to to explore many things you
can think about your own you can support
your customer wants to know what is the
district of my customer like we will get
to some use cases here the idea why to
use API is the
if someone asks you could you find a
playground or could you find a museum
for all vocations in our database you
can look like once twice three or four
times but how many times can you
visually inspect what's in a map I
believe that if you have many or even
more like number of bigger number of
rows you either get desperate or well
I'm going to propose you can use a
source of information which is the rich
on content and which has a decent API
and for me these are open street maps so
if the rest of the presentation I will
show you how to do this inspection of
the map but not visually but how to code
it so that you get gets a feeling of
what three neighborhoods around for many
memories yeah so this is the whole line
we will first decide what we're after
what we're looking for then I will show
you how to find it manually the open
street maps and that's really not a hard
task then we will replicate that manual
search through a query and then we will
put this query into iPhone parameterize
it and serialize and in the end I will
give some hints how to make sure that
you're downloading all points of
interest that are relevant to you and
the use case here is you can be asked
are there any libraries around here so
this is a use case for an online
librarian service that wants to
distribute offers of subscriptions they
have some subscriptions which can be for
free and they want to know which people
if you know
two libraries so they are less likely to
to accept such an offer for which people
live in districts which are deficient or
which are missing libraries although
we're going to illustrate those five
steps on search for our libraries I'm
sure that it holds for all the types of
analyzes so it could be that you want to
find out whether the location where your
customers live is a residential or more
or more industrial or which since I mean
this is a proxy for wealth or I do we
want to live in Oracle con or not in and
prices you can also think about if you
want to compare districts across cities
to find out whether your impression that
you have too little or too many too few
or too many bus stops where whether it
is right it yeah you can look in a map
or for our weekend trips we often want
to find a restaurant which has a
children playground in nearby and indeed
you can go in a map and then zoom and
zoom zoom and zoom to find out where
these places are but it's much better to
run it through api's and i know that my
colleagues and we saw that that they
were delighted by sharing some queries
which find them children backgrounds
with restaurants nearby yeah and what we
were looking for in our libraries so i
said the initial step is to find the
library manually so you go to
www.youtube.com we hope now works fine
and I don't think I want to do live demo
here since I assume you know how to
search in a lot
man and this setup is not really so
helpful for doing demos so what you got
is one one library one arbitrary library
and you don't need to search for any
specific one do you do this search to
prepare for the next step which is to
replicate that search fruit code so this
is a how the description of any node in
the wisdom would look like it shows you
where this library is this tells you
it's met as a knot we will work with
that later it tells you the excitement
it tells you what tags are used to
describe this library and the important
thing here is that feminity is of type
library you also see the street number
and the district and the zip code but
what I want to highlight here that a
manatee library looks very general it
can be used for all libraries where as
indeed not all libraries are in
Australia to commit sin yes so we found
one library so now we must replicate
this through a query and there are two
facts you shall know about osm and this
is how our objects mapped in the
OpenStreetMaps and those two hex are
every object consists of points so be it
a statute within the house be it a river
it's all delimited by points and the
second fact is that every object can be
tagged points are used to really delimit
the location of the object whereas tacks
tell you to tell you the content whether
it's library or a thank you or whatever
else and bit more to this there are
conceptually three types of objects in a
in the OpenStreetMaps so note way and
relation
note is a single point it's a point like
object it can be as a cue the Fontan it
can be a telephone booth simply anything
which on the map you can depict as a as
a point object then you have the way
ways are linear or I would say aerial
objects it can be a road or park some
ways are like they're limited it could
be a court in record of the building
others are open it could be a river
right from the spring to the to the
Delta
yeah and so third one are a relations
and relations think about them as a
collections of other objects the nice
example is the country of Indonesia
right you know it consists of many
islands every island every island was
mapped as a as a polygon which is a way
then a collection of all these islands
would be correlation and that would that
would comprise the entire country of
Indonesia so the first thing we met
object through points and conceptually
there are not there are ways and
relations in the lesson to extend the
other fact tanks are how do you provide
context to the points taking skill
like people was sorry one taking schema
is simple here you
yeah we long for
uncork the tagging works by providing
the pairs of key memory right for a road
you could say key would be surface and
when you asphalt or for a library use so
amenity is a key and library is the
value and the list of features is
something I often oftentimes find myself
surprised by it's extremely rich in
OpenStreetMaps this is a page with the
most prominent features if you look on
the scroller here here on the right you
see it's longer pages long and then for
me or say so this would be station of
aerial way you find whether it's most
often exists in notes or here it's not
same areas how it typically looks like
how it renders in a map and I sort of
like going through this lists it shows
you that the map can contain everything
recommended to go through this
they are subject to slides important
thing I shall say is that there is not
really a schema some limited number of
keys or values in the OSM everyone is
encouraged to enter his or her own panic
everyone is encouraged to contribute to
the map
thanks over the time you can be
contacted by other users telling you
that this as well you shall use surface
as well not as for the yes I think
that's fine
overly I find it very comprehensive yeah
so we do know how to make things and
then you need to know how to query those
objects in OS and database so there is a
dedicated query language in the
OpenStreetMaps
and I find it quite comprehensible you
say what type of objects your query
you're looking for so that will be note
or way or relationship then you use
these parent theses to say what stack
you're interested in right you don't
want to download all the points you want
to defined in our case libraries only
then you use the standard parent thesis
to say where to search you program they
don't want all the libraries on the
globe and then the keyword out and if we
put these two things together this is a
query for death one library so first we
say we're interested in the thoughts
then we are using this tack which we
found on a webpage to filter for
libraries then we I copied these
coordinates like them here and
prepending ten by this operator around I
am looking for libraries 50 meters
around this place and I'm having this
outward here and the query language is
quite rich I find it well rich and at
the same time
easy to learn it I quite happy using it
and you can do many things there for
example if you don't find the library 50
meters you can extend this radius and
the good thing here is that you don't
have to run this code from Python at the
first step since there is a bad API
which is called overpass to vote it's a
bad page which looks like this this is
where you write the code oh here you see
the results you can load your previous
the results or a previous code there are
yeah you can run it share it indeed the
thing is that by running this piece of
code you get you get a pop-up which
contains exactly the same piece of
information as we saw in the manual
search and the good thing is here good
thing here is that not only you see it
visually that's the library I found
manually you also have this data tag and
I will try the second demo now to show
you that this data tab is quite helpful
since it shows you what's what's the
data like no data loaded yet so let's
give it a try understanding that output
device as prerequisites for the next
step fire
yeah so first that results here in the
night yeah looks like we found the same
library and now to do data it's an XML
which tells you what was the what was
the meta base that's the one from this
evening and then this is not is the
library right you see the latitude and
longitude you see the internal ID in the
US
some database you see this amenity
library type here you see the district a
tip code exactly as we found manually
and I hope this all makes sense since
having this code is something that
enables us to search for libraries or
restaurants or bars basically what we do
now is that we I show you how to run
that query in Python right through or
wesam query language we assembled this
piece of code we ran it through overpass
to vote to see that it really works and
retransmit what we want to and all you
need to do to replicate this from Athens
is to wrap it into into some API calls
so I am using a library called a girl I
and on the second line I'm constructing
the API object and then I'm running this
query text against the API and what I
get is a is a list of dictionaries I
think in my gaddafi you find a notebook
with the details but it basically tells
you the first first record in the
dictionary is is this number and then
all these tags are contained as a sorry
the first input in the list is this
number and the second second member of
the list is a dictionary which contains
all these pairs and through this all I
have all the data about that library
which is available
in my computer so really details are in
that notebook which lies next to the
presentation and that there is more in
appendix here there are other libraries
which I tried but I'm really happy with
over by but that really hits my knees so
what's left is till now we were looking
for that one specific library
translating the manual search into into
the query search what I'm going to do
next is to harami tries that and
serialize it and as I said this is the
simplest method parameter I sense he
relies I don't want to charm you with
any highly optimized code I really want
to to to condemn the message that each
of us can start using it right tomorrow
yes so my two parameters are called
latitude and amplitude I'm inserting
that into the query through 4matic it's
the same code as before it's just so
formatting Thanks once I have this I can
run that code through many that if you
set up any longer cutes
combined inclusive and then if that
query many powers and again if you don't
believe that it's that simple please
look into the into my specimen yeah and
that's basically all I wanted to I
wanted to share code wise is here the
last date that remains how to make sure
that you download all the relevant parts
of interest when it comes to relevancy
the OSM contains like I think 12
billions of objects and I assume you
don't want to download 12 billions of
objects you want to find few libraries
which are in your neighborhood already
want to find wheelchair accessible bus
stops
so my recommendation here is use tax
pretty when when preparing these queries
do use tax
it's much easier to go to that webpage
and find out that libraries are not like
that then go through thousands of points
and find out that 90% of them is a
garbage which is not interesting for you
and only find 10% of relevant points
when it comes to downloading all points
of interest I'm always using and it's
good practice which I recommend what
they call Union so by telling and by
telling the the API I am looking for
notes which are libraries and ways which
are libraries and relations which are
libraries you're making sure that the
large libraries like the national one in
the city center here which are meant as
a relations for the solo pod in your in
your result this is an example of
playgrounds which I could close too
close to the Python Python menu and you
see that this playground with this
number is meant as a note whereas this
is some sport center which has a tennis
court and also maybe the swimming pool
and it as a measure playground - but if
I limited myself to looking for notes
only I who committed this one so the
summary here is use tax as a filters and
use this Union syntax which tells the
database give me all notes and wasted
relations right that's it there are many
more specimen queries prepared for you
all of these demonstrate various aspects
of query all of them are published in
the github - so I encourage you to go to
to get help download that code and play
with that it's it's a big fun
the other message I want to I want to
transmit is that it's easy to contribute
to osm it all belongs to the community
right it's not like you're using some
say commercial webpage where you and
list a new place and it belongs to the
commercial company I will do roam over
to OS on to this this editor so this is
the address of Twister and Carlene if
you want to change the opening hours of
this restaurant you click on that you
find the text of them's text at the
restaurant here on the Left we can give
it a try and you just list the updated
opening hours it's if I update the name
I just write it here if I wanted to
update the working hours on this
or it's maybe opening hours so if you
have a fast internet there is a tool of
telling you he wants to you only took of
the opening hours but it's really that
simple
another of how to contribute to OSF is
to download an app which is called map
your away I think
well app for Habitat for in a smartphone
and wherever you go it's asking you for
this street I don't know what's the
surface for this house I don't know the
number and you can really insert it in
the individual affection as you go yeah
we met part of the destinations where we
go for holiday every year so you're
encouraged to start and it's all the
versions so if you accidentally delete
anything it's fine it can be restored
easily yeah so back to my slides I think
yeah we're at the end there is a long
appendix question so I am happy to
answer your questions and possibly to we
can go for that but that's really all
for now please there is some boolean
logics in the queries right could you
say I'm either looking for a trans tops
or for a bus stops yes it is and it
could be a little my examples I don't I
can't really tell you the code by heart
but the other there is there is also
concept which I found you know Bell that
it could be that for those of you who
are developers that you know that it's
called it's called the recursion I think
and that's if you say you're looking for
points which are close to the border of
the Czech Republic and one of those
points hit the border you may be
interested in all all ways or relations
where points around your
there is where they occur so using that
I found the entire border of Czech
Republic by looking for one point only
since I used the recursion which told
the query I am interested in all the
relations which are somehow related to
the point close to it was a suburb of
jg9 with the or and it's definitely
there for example asks for points that
are in your vicinity of meters and
something can you can you some of this
crap in every other you are looking for
like for example number 2 if you if you
provide it with the polygon one of the
demos prepare so we were filtering
through this tank library right the
other option is to use name like drag -
or I set amenity equals library so I
provided both the key and the value so
you can look through piece only or
through values only and you can even use
the regular expressions and let me see
whether there is an example here yeah
this example is with this with regular
expression
and I was looking for libraries or
laying around this is a way how you say
or I'm not sure there isn't a with with
Lane name no there is not but I learned
all of this from the page they are
looking for here we go
is it possible to search for rules using
a with some API how many requests per
day is what allowed to do so the answer
to the first question is definitely yes
I'm not sure it's this API so overpass
is for downloading or uploading as small
numbers of points but for for routing
that there is another API which I used
again Poland but I don't really remember
it later but there is definitely an API
for a routing only there you can specify
I'm interested in cycling roads which
are behaved or as for the river how many
requests per day is one allowed to do I
don't think it's tracked you don't even
need the registration you can run all
these queries from your computer right
now with with no subscription but there
is some human mechanism and if there are
many requests you get at the end of the
queue and to your waiting the other
option which you have if you wanted to
run many requests is to download the
entire OS on to your local machine let's
call for example planet osmosis
one of their products and then that they
publish the entire world every day and
each content four times of day and you
can run those queries at your local or I
mean in your company so then if you no
longer have limitations
I'm think so hundreds of gigabytes and
larger but you cannot you - you don't
need to download the entire entire world
right you would be interested in parts
of the Europe I think I can also promote
this as novelty and they they offer you
offline I think and for using and the
mapping background are actually always a
match and you know you can download the
summer in Germany or western Austria and
that it's much smaller but the entire
world was hundreds walking about
[Music]
some of this incorporates public
transport routes directly into oh yes
the question is whether you could
incorporate the roles of a public public
transport yes it's there so an example
I'm not showing here is but I can query
how many trend stops ago around our
building in Carly why don't we stop for
a fourth I spoke about the recovery so
in Carly and you have this via book for
this bridge for a railways so if you do
for all relations close to our office
you found the railway track from
grandmas are coming out nom-a-nom trashy
to ground open up the Davao you find the
name of this of these tracks with this
past seven I think and it's all there
there are no time tangles there but you
can find out that what the single stone
belongs to this public transport and is
the same for trams and 49th trends and
for a night buses
yeah so you would switch to that are you
asking how to incorporate that right yes
yeah so in the map you would you would
first list the tram stops rather there
might be one not sure but you would
enlist the points as a tram stops and
then you would connect these points
through away I guess and you would tag
that this way has the members these tram
stops and you would tag that it's a
tramway so wait for a train race you
would probably damaged by it would be
trend number nine and then you could say
this is a daytime train train sorry they
tie track and so on up its eyes already
even if you want to do this say a
building you start by listing this
corner it is for this paym discovered
and then these four corners and you say
my my way since building is an area
highways or between these two polygons
the do typically start will curl with
stops by parents
yes not ethically people get away you
Mozilla something question is I'm
speaking about ways
what polygons are not necessarily ways
so they have a two concept one of them
is about what you describe and then they
speak about polygons which is close or I
think surface is the other one which can
be open but conceptually they put it
into one one book which is called way
but that's the ways but you're right
I've noticed that in the wiki again
that's that there are various well
attitudes how to call it depending on
whether you're mapping or what really
wants to best describe what it's what
it's about and there was another
question in spider I think would you can
listen to metal objects which are
provided by the latitude and
there is no but what you could do is see
to take to metro boat but the boat
itself let me see the salute question
here we go
I was number of quality of objects see
that or a people maps so in Czech
Republic Google Maps are quite good and
I think the reason is that we have a
strong local competitor here in Poland
there is no Mathis easy and twister
expanded to Poland last year and we find
the level or the content of Google Maps
much less reliable and then you can
resort to no assigned to to retrieve
more very indeed the content is created
by the community so if there are people
in Poland who are willing to explore the
Polish pedestrian and you
it's only have two people who are
nothing if they are neighborhoods it can
be questionable but in the city center
of Varsha
I learned that English machine for a
small column which is located next to
the pavements where the cars are the
party of the road party of the pavement
these columns Boulder with them one by
one
what I also know is the mantasy that
allows you to search for children this
is my model and I think there is no
official Republic wide source of
playgrounds under them OS and
playgrounds but I'm happy that my PC
that provides this search for people who
are still I think that the Wesson might
contain a bit more than my PC that this
is my personal impression right is it
working the maps are cute is it possible
to you or commercial purposes yes yes it
is
so my pcs that are provided by itself a
very good example of commercial service
which was using over some it's all three
all you I think she'll do but it's more
Morales then bigger must contribute back
it's like with any open software right
you you're encouraged to use it and it's
up to you whether you contribute back
yeah so it's used for commercial versus
that's the project it opens a pop-up
survey so the question was who is
running OSI do I know anything about the
infrastructure I don't really know
I'm data scientist using the data from
home assignments I'm also paying back by
contributing by the points but I really
don't know how this works how to
distribute it or centralized
[Applause]